[MUSIC PLAYING]
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: Hello.
MATIAS DUARTE: Hi, everyone.
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY:
Matias and I have
been talking about
how we were going
to-- what kind of fireside--
by the way, no fire
to be near at all here.
Very upsetting.
We were talking
about how we were
going to have this conversation
because historically, I've
interviewed Matias about
various topics, usually design.
But we thought it
would be interesting
if we interviewed each
other, and so we both have
a set of cards
today and we're both
going to be asking questions.
And it could be a disaster,
or could be magical,
or something in the middle.
So Matias, I think
you wanted to lead.
MATIAS DUARTE: I did.
Thank you, Josh.
Good morning again.
We've been talking for about
10 years, I think, on and off,
different products.
And it's always
been in the context
of looking at the products
that me or my team
have been responsible
for designing.
And you and your team have been
doing this kind of critique
and reporting on,
I think, products
from a lot of people in
the audience as well.
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: Yeah.
We've been tearing
down and tearing apart
your hard work for
years and years.
MATIAS DUARTE: Heartless,
honest criticism.
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: Brutal.
MATIAS DUARTE: But that was
actually my first question.
Normally, your
stage is one where
you're critiquing
products and results.
What would you say
to this audience
if you have an opportunity
to talk before they actually
create a product?
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: Well, it
depends on what kind of product
you're talking about.
But I will say-- you
know what I would
say if I could talk to
anybody before they create
a product, particularly
companies that are large,
the Google size companies?
MATIAS DUARTE: Oh, I see.
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY:
I think, actually,
Google does a pretty good job--
MATIAS DUARTE: Just
a few of those.
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: But
not everybody does.
What I would say is
don't do focus groups.
Don't listen to small
groups of people
that you bring into a room and
ask them specific questions
about how you make a product.
I would say make a product
that you think is awesome
and that you love and that the
people that you know and care
about and understand
get how it works
and like it and want to use it.
Because I've seen
so many companies
do this thing where they go in.
You'll go into a
meeting with them
and they show you this
product and they say,
we did user testing and we found
that 9 times out of 10, users
prefer this to this other thing.
And it's like your group
is so weird and small.
You put them in such
an odd environment.
And you can learn
some things about how
people-- how the general public
might interact with something.
But that I think the best
design, the best products,
come from really
smart people trying
to solve their own problems.
Trying to solve problems that
they really deeply understand.
And so when you
get to a situation
where you're trying to solve
somebody else's problems
and you're using these very
artificial environments
to validate whether
your solve has worked,
I feel like it can
often lead to disaster.
So I guess what I'm saying
is follow your heart when
it comes to design.
That make sense?
MATIAS DUARTE:
That's inspirational.
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: Is
that what you're doing?
MATIAS DUARTE:
Follow your heart.
That's good.
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: Do
you find that you're
doing that at Google?
Are you following your heart?
MATIAS DUARTE: We don't--
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: Or are
you following a mandate
from far beyond you?
MATIAS DUARTE: Not a mandate.
That's actually a good question.
Because it really
resonates with me
when you talk about
not doing focus groups,
not trying to decide
what is the right course
to pursue by kind of
being unopinionated.
I actually think design
always should be opinionated.
But it bothers me a little bit
to think about design being
limited to solving
your own problems only.
I mean, I almost
think it's easier
to solve your own problems.
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: Really?
When people have as
many problems as they do
[INAUDIBLE]?
I feel like my life
would be way easier
if I could solve
my own problems.
MATIAS DUARTE: Not in that way.
Not in that way.
Right?
What I mean is, one of
the biggest challenges
we have as designers
is to pull ourselves
and our own perspective
out of the problems.
It's to really understand
somebody else's problems.
And I don't think
focus groups are a way
to understand whether
you've successfully
solved the other
person's problem or not.
Maybe it's one of-- I actually
dislike focus groups because I
think of them mostly
as a marketing tool.
But there is all sorts of
different types of research
techniques that
are about gaining
an understanding of
different people, people
who are different than
you and putting yourself
in their point of view.
We had dinner last
night and somebody
was railing against empathy
as an overused buzzword.
So I think we're going to
have to have the empathy shot
drinking game whenever
that word gets used.
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: Well,
we do have these drinks.
MATIAS DUARTE: We do.
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY:
Matias and I thought
it would be great
to have mimosas
in the morning on stage.
MATIAS DUARTE:
Terrible or brilliant.
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: I don't
know if it was a great idea.
MATIAS DUARTE: I don't think so.
But as much as empathy
might be abused--
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY:
So we have to drink
every time you say empathy?
Is that the game?
MATIAS DUARTE: Yeah,
you keep drinking.
I'm just going to
keep saying it.
As much as it might
be abused or misused,
I actually think that
concept of putting yourself
in somebody else's
shoes, of stepping out
of your needs and your values,
that's really important.
That's really critical.
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: I'm not saying
don't think about other people.
What I'm saying is
don't create an--
MATIAS DUARTE: Yes, you are.
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY:
No, I'm saying don't
create an artificial
environment where
you think you're
going to figure out
what the problems
of other people are.
I think-- maybe
I can expand this
and say I'm saying solve
problems that you see,
that you understand.
But I feel like when you
put people in an environment
where you're sort
of artificially
asking them to
give you feedback,
you don't end up with the
right kind of feedback.
I do think data is powerful.
I think using data
in the right way--
MATIAS DUARTE: Behavioral
data is powerful.
Asking people opinions really
can be valuable, but fraught
with danger, right?
People are not very good
observers of themselves.
They're not very good
judges of their own value.
I think anybody who
has kids knows this.
What's the famous line?
Where if you asked a million
people to design a car for you,
they'd all have cup
holders and mini fridges
and V8 engines and--
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY:
American car, you're
talking about an American car.
It would be the entire car
would be cup holders, no seats.
All right.
So--
MATIAS DUARTE: Throw one at me.
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: You disagree
with my basic concept
about my advice for designers.
So we actually were
talking about-- I saw you
in New York-- we have a
lot of social engagements.
I saw you in New York and we
were talking about UI design
and where everything is going.
We've talked about
this, obviously,
throughout the years.
And if you look across, now,
the major platforms in mobile,
Android, iOS,
Windows Phone-- yes,
I'm throwing that in there.
It is a platform that exists.
So if you look across
those platforms,
and a lot of those
platforms are starting
to inform what we see on
other screen sizes, right?
If you look at the
new OS, OS X, it's
very much like mimicking
what has happened in iOS.
Obviously across
Google products,
Chromebooks and Chrome
and email and everything
is moving towards
a unified place.
But it's a very-- to me, and
if you look at Windows Phone,
it's actually sort of
in a very similar space.
It's very flat, it's very
clean, it's very spacious.
And I'm not saying
that I want to have
skeuomorphic be a thing again.
But I do feel like--
I mean, have we
lost a little bit of-- are we
past the moment where people
are really excited about what
you could do in those spaces?
And are we in the little valley
between the peaks where we're
going to just ride this very
familiar, very similar--
Because honestly, you could
put an iOS device and something
with material design in
front of a random person who
doesn't really
know the platforms
and they may not be able to
tell you that they're different,
dramatically
different platforms.
Apple even has a
back motion now.
You've got your back button,
they've got their Swype.
So are we in the valley of
sameness right now in design?
MATIAS DUARTE: So you're
saying you're bored.
As a technologist, you're bored.
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: I'm
saying I miss felt
and other surface--
I miss wood textures.
No, but I'm saying
that it is-- things
are not as differentiated
as they once were.
I actually booted up a
Palm device the other day,
because I'm sick person.
A very sick person.
MATIAS DUARTE: I saw that.
Spotify still works, apparently.
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: Spotify still
works, which is really insane.
Kudos to Spotify, by
the way, for really
keeping legacy products going.
But yeah, I looked
at that and it
felt like the old--
it felt very much
like that old, the early days
of when we were figuring out,
it was very
skeuomorphic, there's
some skeuomorphic
stuff going on there.
So I don't know.
Yeah, I feel like we're a
little bit of a down period.
I mean, material
design is beautiful.
I'm contractually obligated to
say that to you while I'm here.
MATIAS DUARTE: I
think you actually
have-- you have to say it
three more times before you
get offstage.
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: Perhaps the
most beautiful mobile operating
system that's ever been created.
I have one more
and I hit my quota.
So tell me, what do you think?
Am I crazy?
Can you empathize
with what I'm saying?
MATIAS DUARTE: Now
you have to drink.
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: I
think you have to drink.
MATIAS DUARTE: No,
I think it's true.
There is a certain sense
of fashion, I think,
that starts to play into
design that we see now.
Actually, kind of,
it was always there.
I'm almost tempted
to say that there's
a fashion in digital design that
maybe is more pronounced now
because some of the
technology is more mature.
Some of the capabilities, in
terms of resolution, rendering,
and animation and everything
is more pronounced.
And so that gives us kind of
a greater expressive range.
And with that greater
expressive range,
we now have a little bit
of a sense of fashion.
I think there's also an
element of fundamental needs
and convergent common
successful solutions.
It's kind of like
the keyboard thing.
You have the QWERTY keyboard,
and the DVORAK keyboard
is superior to it in terms
of theoretical efficiency--
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: Do you
personally feel that?
MATIAS DUARTE: I haven't
done the studies,
but according to what I
read, in terms of pure typing
efficiency, it should be better.
But it's this marginal
improvement, and so, you know,
it's OK.
Everybody sticks with
the standard keyboard.
Right now, you'd
be insane to try
to launch a product that has
a keyboard concept, right,
like a display, whether
it's virtual or physical,
that has a keyboard
layout that's not QWERTY.
I see this all the
time, like I see
a television will come out and
be like, A, B, C, D, E, F, G.
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: That's actually
very common on television.
MATIAS DUARTE: I
know, it's crazy.
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: Is just
a standard keyboard layout
better on a television?
Is that easier for
us to parse when
you're that abstracted
from the surface?
MATIAS DUARTE: I don't
know that it's better.
It's just, it it's
familiar enough
that the familiarity
kind of overwhelms
the potential
optimized benefits.
We were talking
about this before.
There's always this
tension between doing
something new that's marginally
better and the switching costs.
And so I think there are periods
of consolidation, if you will,
or settling in terms of--
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: Valleys.
MATIAS DUARTE: --paradigms.
I think of them
more as plateaus.
I like to be
optimistic about it.
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: That is a very
pessimistic view, isn't it?
MATIAS DUARTE: Yeah.
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: I guess-- well,
plateau also sounds bad to me.
MATIAS DUARTE: Why?
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: If you've
reached-- that's it.
You're flatlined up there.
MATIAS DUARTE: It's
a stable place.
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: How
can you go beyond it?
What are you going to do?
MATIAS DUARTE: But that's
the challenge, right?
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: Tell us
how you're going to go--
MATIAS DUARTE: In
order to go beyond,
I think you need to
provide a lot more value.
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: OK, I get that.
I think that makes sense.
MATIAS DUARTE: So let
me ask you a question.
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: Oh boy.
Yeah.
MATIAS DUARTE: So now
you're at Bloomberg.
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: Yes.
MATIAS DUARTE: No longer
a tech journalist--
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY:
Well, I still dabble.
MATIAS DUARTE:
--model slash actor.
Now you're just journalist.
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: I
also model slash actor.
Don't forget about my side job.
MATIAS DUARTE: That's true.
But you were talking about
some of design challenges
that you have there, right?
So this seems like
it's not just something
you're observing in the world.
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: I
actually have a card
that I was going
to ask you, which
is, does print design
make you a little angry?
MATIAS DUARTE: I hear
it makes you angry.
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: You know
what, I mean, here's the thing.
So before going to Bloomberg,
I was at a startup.
And we were all digital.
There was no paper
component anywhere.
By the way, there's
probably a lot
of people in this room who are
not going to feel this at all.
There are people sitting in this
room who are app developers,
and they're working completely
in the digital space,
and they don't care
about print at all.
And I didn't care about
print at all, really.
I mean, I love
reading magazines,
but I never had to think--
MATIAS DUARTE: So you went from
neglect to downright anger.
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: I never
had to think about it.
So I came to Bloomberg,
and they have
a publication called
"Business Week."
I think it's brilliant,
one of the best paper
magazines in the world.
I think it's incredible.
And then I started
sitting and watch--
I would watch the design
teams design for print.
And I started to formulate this.
Of course, I've
always known this,
but I started to think,
god, this is so annoying.
You have a set page size.
You know there's one thing
you can do with the page.
You're going to
look at it and then
turn it over to the next page.
And what a dream it must
be to sit down every day
and go, how can I make
this fixed thing that I can
do anything I want to
in terms of design, how
can I make this look good?
And so I started to
get a little bit angry
as we were going
through the process.
We just launched a site called
Bloomberg Politics where
we were going
through this process
of how do you bring
the best of print
and how do you make
something feel really--
News design is
actually difficult,
and it's a real practice.
And how do you bring traditional
news design to the web?
I think we move the ball
little bit with The Verge.
And then I'm trying
to do some new things
and take it somewhere
new at Bloomberg,
but it was really frustrating,
because you get to these places
where you have this
beautiful design
and you're like, oh,
wait a second, when
it goes to a mobile
phone it looks bad.
Or oh, we forgot about
the three by two.
Does everybody know
what a three by two is?
Raise your hand if you know
what a three by two is.
Really?
Nobody?
MATIAS DUARTE: Yes, see?
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: One person.
MATIAS DUARTE: Nobody knows.
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: Two people.
MATIAS DUARTE: What
is this three by two?
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: OK,
if you're doing design
for the web in an ad
supported environment,
there's an ad unit which
is 300 by 250 pixels.
It's on every
website in the world.
It sits in the-- usually
in the right hand corner.
And as you start to
design for the web,
and particularly in news design,
which is information dense,
you realize that we're really
just designing around--
it must be wonderful
for people who
don't have to think
about advertising.
We're designing around
the three by two.
That's basically the main
anchor of design on the web
if you're dealing
with advertising.
And it's totally insane.
And it's been happening
for like 20 years.
And there's no way to
stop, because advertisers
are-- they don't
move that quickly.
They certainly don't move as
quickly as people in this room.
Anyhow, so it's just
very frustrating
when you look at what it's
like to design for a very
static place versus
designing for,
now, every breakpoint
you can possibly imagine
imagine, every view type
you can possibly dream of.
So I got very frustrated.
I got very mad at-- I mean,
I love the print designers,
but I kind of shake my fist
every time I walk past.
You don't have to worry
about that, though.
And you don't have
to worry about ads.
That's a whole
other part of Google
that has to worry about ads.
All you have to do is
make beautiful things.
How I'm getting angry at you.
But it is it-- I'm actually--
MATIAS DUARTE: We have
lots of sizes to work with.
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: I'm
actually curious--
MATIAS DUARTE: Have
some empathy for me.
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: Oh yeah,
I have a lot of empathy.
So I actually was talking
to some your Google buddies
about the process for design.
And you've got-- you're
focused largely on Android,
I mean, the design that
you're doing touches
all sorts of other things.
But you're not the only
person doing design at Google.
There are other
pieces of the company.
There's Chrome.
MATIAS DUARTE: It used to
be that Google would only
have one designer, but
we've gone past that.
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY:
Just one guy, they
would just put
stuff on his desk.
But no, you've got a Chrome
team, you've got an email team.
You've got all these
designers spread
across lots of
different products, lots
of different breakpoints.
So how do you-- how would a
company the size of Google,
and one that has historically
not been known, I mean,
if we look back not that
long ago at Google design,
we look at things
like Honeycomb.
Does anybody remember
Honeycomb on Android?
It looked like Tron.
And older Google products
not that long ago.
Google Reader, think about what
it used to actually look like.
Not known for design.
How do you get
everybody together
and start collaborating
on good design
that is not just
beautiful and useful,
but that is aligned across
all these different silos?
Maybe they're not silos.
MATIAS DUARTE:
Yeah, I don't know
if there's any general
lessons to be drawn from it,
but just speaking from our
experience, material design,
kind of as a story,
as a back story,
it's kind of like an insurgency.
It was not a formal, top
down kind of process.
But it came, at a
certain point, to take
on that character,
where we did take
on a mantle of authority
which was necessary,
I think to drive as
much change as we did.
But initially, it really
was the design leaders
in various groups who
were all heads down,
trying to make things better.
And we just built relationships.
And we'd sit around
and we'd talk about
what are we going to do.
And all of a sudden this idea
started to kind of trickle
together, like, well, we if
we kind of did this together?
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: So you formed--
MATIAS DUARTE: A cabal.
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: A committee.
MATIAS DUARTE: No,
not a committee.
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: You'd say
it is design by committee.
Is that how you
would describe it?
MATIAS DUARTE: No.
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: But
what you described
does sound kind of a little
bit like a committee,
you will agree.
MATIAS DUARTE: I don't think so.
It's a group of designers.
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: A cabal.
MATIAS DUARTE: A cabal.
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: OK.
MATIAS DUARTE: I
think all large design
problems have to be
tackled by groups.
Typically, a lot of
these groups have
kind of a formal organization
or formal authority.
And we took on a formal
authority at Google
with material design later.
But initially it
really was informal.
It was a set of--
No, I'm going to wrap
the flag around myself.
I'm going to say it was
a set of design patriots
who rallied together under
a common vision and said,
you know what, we're
going to risk it,
we're going to try to do this.
And that's kind of
how it happened.
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: So does that
touch everything at Google now?
I mean, will all products--
does material design
become a bible at Google
for how you do design?
MATIAS DUARTE: It
becomes a guideline.
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: Not a bible.
MATIAS DUARTE: Yeah,
we're not big on bibles.
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: You
don't want to say
that a committee
produced the Bible, is
that what you're telling me?
MATIAS DUARTE: A committee did
produce the Bible, actually.
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: That's a
rabbit hole you probably
don't want to go down
this early in the morning.
But getting back to Google,
you've got disparate teams,
right?
You've got people who've got
to design a lot of products
for a lot different
places, but they
have to work off of something.
So you've got to get buy in.
Is it just collective?
Collectively, people
buy in and say,
of course we want this design?
Don't you have dissent?
Aren't there people who say,
why is that button down there?
MATIAS DUARTE: Oh sure, yeah.
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: What
do you do to them?
MATIAS DUARTE: Yeah, it
happens all the time.
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY:
Where do you put them?
MATIAS DUARTE: Well, you
do-- at a certain point,
you have to make decisions.
So we have a small
team that is actually
responsible for material design
as a product, as a thing,
as a guideline.
This is no different
than any other company.
At a certain point,
you reach a scale
where somebody has to be
responsible for the brand book
or somebody has to be
responsible for a UI
guidelines.
Somebody has to be responsible
for a higher level structure.
And the teams have
to work with that.
And it's actually
one of things I
think is really
interesting about creating
guidelines and
creating structures.
There's a very fine
balance between giving
too little guidance and actually
not helping people and giving
so much guidance you become
kind of a straitjacket.
What I like to do--
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: Wait, give
me a real world example
of both of those scenarios.
That's very vague, but
give me a specific example
of what you're talking about.
MATIAS DUARTE: Well, OK.
Take anything in the
material design guidelines.
The spec.
I don't know if in fact we
actually use spec externally.
We always called it
the spec internally.
So take anything.
Take the FAB, the big
primary action button.
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY:
The thing that's
in the right hand corner?
MATIAS DUARTE: The thing that
can sit in the right hand
corner or really can
sit anywhere on screen.
And actually, the position
is a perfect example of this.
We recognized that there
was a drive and desire
to elevate the most important
functions of an application.
And in fact, there's
kind of a design forcing
function that's really positive
that happens where you say,
OK, you have an opportunity
to say your application is
about the content
that you see on screen
and one additional kind of
metaconcept, something that
can't be visualized
with content.
And when you do that, you
get simpler interactions.
You get simpler products.
You get simpler designs.
So let's create this
design pattern that says,
this is how you should do this.
This is how things should look.
We're going to
take this one thing
and we're going to elevate it
literally on a higher surface,
call it out with color, with
shape, give you all these cues
to say this is really important.
So we had all sorts of
examples of how to do this.
And one of the
things that we liked
in the process of
calling that out
is that we liked that it
breaks across borders.
So it either sits
on top of content
or, even more
dramatically, it sits
across a breakpoint of content.
So it can sit where a card
surface goes onto a background,
and it can sit half
and half on that.
Or between a header and a
lower piece of content, and it
can sit half and half on that.
And the tension of
breaking that line
draws even more
attention to the object.
So it's all these
practical layout tricks
that help elevate the
user's focus to it.
So then an app says, does
this make sense for me?
Does this make
sense for my screen?
I've got a product and
there's no primary meta-thing
that I want to elevate, like
new or star or whatever it is.
Do I need to do it?
Does it make sense?
And you can sit
down and you can try
to encapsulate a huge
amount of guidance
on all of the nuanced
exceptions for why you might not
want to do this or why you might
want to do it in a slightly
unconventional
position, or you might
want to do it in a
slightly different way.
I don't think that's
actually helpful.
I think the role
of the guidelines
is to provide the basic rules,
to provide the basic structure.
They're like teaching people
about composition or about
contrast.
It doesn't mean that in
your particular case,
in your particular
design problem,
there isn't a reason to mess
with that, to violate it,
to play with it, to go
in a different direction.
But if you try to capture
all that nuance in the rules,
you end up actually not helping
people who, 99% of the time,
are just trying to
be like, all right,
I just need to get through this.
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY:
Do you worry that
with that kind of--
do you worry there
we're simplifying
too much in design?
That things are
becoming so simplistic
that we're actually removing
features that are useful?
I feel like there's an idea
that for something to be better,
it has to be more
simplistic and easier
to understand at first blush.
But we also know that some
of the most powerful things
require learning.
Some the most powerful tools the
probably everybody in this room
uses require you
to learn the tool.
And when you first see it,
when you first look at it,
you don't know what
everything does,
and you don't know why
it has certain functions.
Do you worry that-- I feel like
as we move to smaller screens,
into tablets and
into phones and those
are our main points
of interaction,
that we are losing some
complexity in what apps do,
in what our tools do.
Does that worry you at all?
Because material
design is-- it does
kind of bury some
complex actions,
but it is very simplistic
in presentation.
So how much of
your time is spent
pulling out features and
making things more simplistic?
And does that-- should
we all be very worried?
MATIAS DUARTE:
Well again, I think
what you want is
a framework that
allows you to have the
conversation about how
you could simplify.
Like when you first
went to mobile,
one of the biggest
benefits of going to mobile
was not any of the specific
design patterns that came out
of it, but simply the
constraint of the screen
is too damn small.
You just cannot put
all that stuff on it.
You have more variety of
more focused tools instead of
one large tool that
has a lot of complexity
where you only ever use
a small percentage of it,
but you're burdened by
all this complexity,
even though you only want
to use a small part of it.
That doesn't mean there
isn't room for these larger
more powerful tools.
Actually, you're talking
about-- you're kind of bored
with the way a lot of the
tools and a lot of interactions
we have today are converging
or perhaps reaching
some kind of status quo.
But I think there are
still pretty interesting
new opportunities that
are totally untapped.
And the way that simple
tools work together, I think,
is one of those.
I think about how we wrote these
questions on these note cards.
We did this with just the
Sharpie and the note card.
And the Sharpie
and the note card
is really powerful, because you
can draw just about anything
on the note card.
It's an incredibly
powerful tool,
but it's also really simple.
All it does is it's going
to create words or images.
But one of the things that you
do with a Sharpie or a note
card, then you combine
it with another tool.
You're like, as
designers, you know,
you've got Sharpies and
note cards and push pins
or sticker tape and a wall.
And now you've got a
totally different tool.
It used to be that--
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: Now
you're making a scrapbook.
MATIAS DUARTE: You're
making it a board, a wall.
You can have a brainstorm--
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: You're
decorating a dorm room.
MATIAS DUARTE: So I
think that's actually
one of the places that's a
really open frontier, is how we
get all of our more simple,
more intuitive, more
focused tools to work better
together, to work in concert
and to do things with them
together in seamless ways
that they couldn't do
just by themselves.
I think that's actually
a much more natural way
to build complexity.
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY:
You're not talking
about making products that work
with Sharpies and note cards.
You're talking about
making products
that are aware of each other
and aware of environments.
MATIAS DUARTE: Sure.
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: Am I correct
in understanding that?
MATIAS DUARTE: That can exchange
capabilities and information
with each other more fluidly.
Right now, you have a lot of
these very focused products,
but except for a few very coarse
interchanges like cut, copy,
and paste and drag and drop,
these products are very siloed.
The capabilities that live in
one product is very isolated.
When an image is taken out
of a photo editing app that
has filters and it's embedded
into another application,
it loses all of the complex
history and metadata
that came with those filters.
When a place is taken out of a
map and it's put into an email
or into a chat, it
loses all the richness
that came with the
map application.
But in the real world, the tools
that we've built everything
around us, everything physical
around us, that doesn't happen.
When you combine
a hammer and a saw
and a screwdriver
and a piece of wood,
they become larger than
the sum of their parts.
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: So
is this something
that you're working
on, something
that Google is working on?
MATIAS DUARTE: It's something
I'd like us to work on.
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: So
you're not working on it.
MATIAS DUARTE: I'm
passionate about it.
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: So
is this-- would this
be a collection of products
that interact with one another,
or would this be something
that is, suddenly
software is much more
aware of the rest of what
the discrete pieces
of software are
doing within an environment?
MATIAS DUARTE: I don't know.
I don't know.
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: I
feel like you do know
and you're not telling me.
MATIAS DUARTE: No, sorry.
No, I think I think it's one
of the unexplored frontiers.
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: Because what
you said was very specific.
That wasn't just
like a random fantasy
you just had about
something you'd like to do.
I'm not needling
you for information.
I'm just saying--
MATIAS DUARTE: Yes, you are.
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: Well, I'm
just saying you were very,
some would say hyperspecific
about the kinds of interactions
you're talking about.
I mean, phones, in your
phones, your tablets,
your software doesn't
currently do that.
MATIAS DUARTE: No.
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: Although Google
just did invent, basically,
short term memory, right?
For-- do you not want
to talk about that?
The AI?
MATIAS DUARTE: Oh yeah,
the artificial intelligence
[INAUDIBLE] has done.
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY:
Is that something
that could be utilized in this--
MATIAS DUARTE: Maybe.
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: Now I feel
like I'm getting somewhere.
Now I think we're
really on to something.
MATIAS DUARTE: Yeah,
on to something?
The future of design?
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: The future.
Well, I mean, design--
MATIAS DUARTE: I
was going to say
that one of the interesting
things to me is right now,
I think design
matters a huge amount
in the creation of
products and services
because it's so easy to pour
so much love and attention
and craft into these
hyper-focused experiences.
And I think it's going to be
a big challenge for designers
and for the tools that we
use to take that into a world
where all of a sudden these
tools have to start working
with each other more fluidly.
That's going to be a big change
in how we think about things.
And I think that there's a whole
wave of these kinds of changes,
challenges to us
that are coming.
Right now I see, kind
of poking my head up
and I'm like, what
I worry about today
in terms of how do
we design something?
And it's like everything
has to move all of a sudden.
It is just not OK
to have anything
be a static,
nonresponsive layout.
Everything has to scale from
different shapes and sizes.
Every single transition and
interaction and every piece
of feedback, you
just expect it to be
crafted and
carefully considered.
And I'm like, oh my god.
Where am I going to get
all these motion designers?
I don't think there
are enough of them.
I don't know.
But that's the
challenge of today.
The thing that's also coming
right around the corner which
seems even more daunting is we
get all these motion designers
and it totally disrupts the
way that our barely functioning
practices are able to work.
Like, we're barely able to
deal with our ethnography
and our research and the
engineering development cycle
and getting the layout
and the visual design
to happen in the right
type of iteration
and get feedback
and all of that.
We're stumbling,
we're figuring it out.
At least, I feel that way.
I don't know, maybe
other people feel
like they've got it figured
out and they just go.
But it feels like
every product I
do, every product
my team does, it's
so much room for improvement.
And then, bam, here comes this
additional need of motion.
And where's the time
going to come from that?
Where is the understanding
and the education
from the other disciplines who
are like, what do you mean?
Why do I have to take this time?
Why do I have to
take this space?
Why do I need room so that
this part of my layout
doesn't overlap each other
so that the motion doesn't
feel complicated?
That's hugely disruptive.
But then, when we start
talking about our products
and our designs not living in
these hermetic silos of just
themselves, but having to
actually sit up against others,
actually dance
together with others,
that's going to change
the way that we design.
It's a different
type of control.
type of direction.
We're no longer going
to be orchestrating
every single move and
every single pixel.
We're going to be
doing something
that maybe is more
like jazz improvisation
or like DJing or something
where there's other actors that
have their own agendas and
their own needs in the design
that we can't account for.
We can't possibly predict
what all these other apps, all
these other services, all
these other designs that
are going to plug into my
design are going to do.
And yet, somehow we have to have
a flexibility in our designs
to accommodate that.
And that's coming.
And then on top
of that, and this,
I think, gets to where maybe
some kind of machine learning
or more intelligent
computing systems can help,
is the fact that today, even
with all of these meticulously
crafted experiences that
we have where we say,
you know what, we're not going
to try to create the word
processor for everybody.
We're going to create the
one that's for hipster coffee
drinking writers in New
York who are journalists,
and we're going to create
the finger painting app--
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: I feel
like you have weirdly
insulted me just now.
MATIAS DUARTE: That
was oddly specific.
I don't know.
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: Hyperspecific.
MATIAS DUARTE: I
just went there.
But we don't-- even
when we do that,
even when our products are
focused on a very specific
target market, they're
still very generic.
We spend all of our time
is designers prioritizing
use cases and saying,
you're not important enough.
Your use case doesn't
meet the 80% rule.
Why do we have this
thing in material design
that says, elevate
this one action.
It's all about finding
this common pattern.
But if you compare the
diversity of software
to the diversity of
something like clothing,
it's like orders of
magnitude different.
Right now, it feels like
there is one jacket.
It's like, are you wearing
the journalist jacket?
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: I did.
I actually bought it from the
journalist clothing store.
MATIAS DUARTE: There's only
one jacket for journalists.
But in reality, people
are incredibly diverse.
They come from
different cultures,
they have different
capabilities,
they have different tolerance
for information density,
they have different
visual acuity--
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: Yeah,
but there's a hammer,
and the hammer
works really well,
and then there's a nail gun,
and the nail gun works better
for certain situations--
MATIAS DUARTE: If I go
into the hardware store,
there's probably
like 12 hammers.
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY:
Yeah, but that's
just a question of how expensive
a hammer do you want to buy,
which one seems most stylish
to you, I don't know,
because I have my
hammer, obviously--
MATIAS DUARTE: They have
different grips and balance,
I don't know.
This is a theoretical,
I never touch a hammer.
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: No, I get it.
Clearly, neither one of us
have ever gone into a store
and bought a hammer, so
that was a bad example.
But what I'm saying is a
hammer is a hammer is a hammer.
They basically all
do the same thing.
And then there's a nail gun.
That's a very different thing
and for a different kind
of user.
But we've identified certain
tools that just work really
well across user sets.
So I totally get what you're
saying about personalization,
which I think has been tried
and failed in many instances.
I know that I've
had a lot of debates
about should people be able to
personalize their news page,
do we want people to show me,
I want to see this up here
and this thing over here, and
never show me any of this?
And what I think what we
found, not to go down a rabbit
hole here, but what we
found is that it's actually
the job, our job, to show
people what's important,
to tell them what's
important and so on.
And people feel overwhelmed by
having to personalize and think
about where things should live.
So how do you make it
not feel overwhelming?
MATIAS DUARTE: That's kind of
like going into the hardware
store and being like, here's
the tools for making hammers.
Figure out which one
is right for you.
Which is different--
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: Like Build
a Bear, but for hammers.
MATIAS DUARTE: Right-- which
is different than going
to a tailor.
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: Startup
idea, that's freebie.
MATIAS DUARTE: You
probably want to tailor
to get that jacket, right?
You didn't design it.
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: I did
not design this jacket.
MATIAS DUARTE: You went to
some expert who was like, hm,
you're a journalist.
You're this tall--
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: You
went to some expert,
and they were like,
you're a designer.
Let me give you an
extremely loud shirt.
I want people--
they're like, people
need to know what's happening
when you walk down the street.
What's that guy do?
Is he a carpenter?
No.
MATIAS DUARTE: No.
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: He's
got that shirt on.
MATIAS DUARTE: Not a
journalist, that's for sure.
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY:
Not a journalist.
Clearly not a carpenter.
But anyhow--
MATIAS DUARTE:
Reeling this back--
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: You were
talking about my suit.
MATIAS DUARTE: Yeah.
I think there's many of
these different axes that
are going to be radically
changing how we think
about our design practice, that
are going to be challenging all
the things that we think
are the fixed points of what
it is that we do as designers.
Basically in the
exact same way, I
think, that you were saying
you were print designer
and you thought you
how this worked.
Print.
I know how to make
beautiful things,
and all the sudden, when it's
responsive, mind blown, right?
That's coming for every
aspect of what we do.
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: Except print.
And you know, we
actually were-- cause
we're running out of time.
So I think we have to wrap up.
But before we do that, I
have one question for you.
I'm very interested
to know your answer.
What do you think is the
most beautiful object that's
either-- has ever been
created or it exists now?
MATIAS DUARTE: Oh my goodness.
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: I had a
bunch of rapid fire questions
we're not going to get to.
Not empir-- it's an
unempirical thing.
In your opinion.
MATIAS DUARTE: I think
those kinds of questions
are impossible to answer.
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: You're
not going to answer?
MATIAS DUARTE: No, I'm going
to caveat it very temporally.
I was just in Kyoto last week
and I had this experience
of going through the Inari
Temple there with the gates.
The red gates all the
way up the mountain.
And that experience of
being inside that space
was one of the most beautiful
experiences I've had.
There was something that was
just stunning about-- each
of the gates was carefully
considered and crafted,
yet it was very organic
and chaotic as well.
Yet it created enough
structure and rhythm.
It was kind of like architecture
and kind of like music.
And kind of like exercise,
too, because you're actually
climbing up this
ridiculously tall mountain
and it keeps going,
it keeps going,
and you're still in this space.
So that's what comes to mind.
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: That's a
pretty good way to end it.
Matias, thanks so much.
MATIAS DUARTE:
Thank you so much.
JOSHUA TOPOLSKY: Thanks, guys.